en la cama del hospital visiblemente
golpeada y vendada la cara de yelena
está cubierta de tinta verde que se
utiliza para atacar a los críticos del
kremlin ella Explica lo que pasó
sacaron al taxista del carro nos
cuajaron la cabeza e intentaron atarme
las manos a la espalda parece que en
este momento apuñalaron Alexander porque
empezó a salirle sangre de la pierna
recorrieron cierta distancia pero el
motor del carro dejó de funcionar no
pudieron volver a encenderlo Así que nos
arrastraron a un Barranco y empezaron a
golpearnos el abogado defensor de los
Derechos Humanos Alexander nemov declaró
a la prensa que tenía la sensación de
que fueron seguidos desde el Aeropuerto
de Moscú y atacados Poco después de
aterrizar entretenia se dirigían a la
capital brucennie para escuchar El
veredicto de un tribunal sobre la madre
de tres críticos del presidente ramsam
Calderón cayeron es un Aliado
incondicional del líder ruso que
autoproclamó soldado de Putin y que ya
había calificado a yelena de amenaza
terrorista
Miré una transmisión en vivo en la
cuenta de Instagram de kadir off para
ver lo que estaba sucediendo en una
reunión Regional de coronavirus Y fue
Entonces cuando le oí proferir amenazas
directas contra mí
ambos se recuperan ahora y han volado de
vuelta a Moscú escoltados por el premio
Nobel de literatura y editor de la nueva
yaceta la publicación está prohibida en
Rusia seis de sus periodistas han sido
asesinados en las últimas dos décadas
entre ellos Anápolis koff callao que
también investigó los abusos entre chaya
fue asesinada en un atentado en Moscú El
Criminal calificado la agresión a yelena
y Alexander de incidente grave pero se
ha negado a comentar las peticiones de
investigación